hello welcome to my presentation
i am nikki osbourne dialing in today
from new zealand uh thank you for tuning
up now if
you are watching this you probably have
one of these
and a series of events choices and
decision making processes
have got you to be sitting where you are
in this moment
but do you think you'd be able to
recognize and recall what all of those
events are and what decisions
lead you to this point uh probably not
and as i'm talking to you and you're
watching the slides your brain is
engaging in a multitude of tasks that
you have no real conscious aware of
awareness of and how you perceive the
presentation how much you're able to
engage
with the material and whether or not you
stick it out to the end
might have much less to do with how good
i am at presenting the material and much
more to do with
how hungry you are whether you're
distracted by an argument you had with
your partner maybe your kids are in the
next
room uh and
or perhaps you've heard me talk before
and you've already formed an impression
of me
or maybe you're critical of the need to
understand cognitive bias
maybe you're sitting there watching in
your pajamas or uh
sitting in bed anyway my point is
before i've even begun the thoughts and
stories in your subconscious
are going to be informing your conscious
perception of my words and the material
and and your ability to understand will
have a lot more to do with what's going
on
underneath and that's just a function of
being human
so our brains are cons constantly taking
shortcuts in order to perceive the world
around us
and this helps us to make decisions
quickly and efficiently
so grab a pen and paper if you have it
handy and
i'm going to get you warmed up get your
brain warmed up before we get into the
good stuff
so count how many x
are in the following sentence
right have you done that you've had a
read
how many have you got three four five
most people who haven't seen this before
will see four
in fact there are six
and the reason that you probably didn't
see
the ones uh that's ended and of
are because your brain fills in the gaps
knowing that
of the and these weird words
don't have meaning um so you look for
the finished files probably
maybe scientific you saw the f in there
but all the words in between
uh essentially don't have meaning and
you're and they're filler words and your
brain just skips
over them what does this slide say
perhaps if i gave you an extra couple of
seconds you may
you you may notice that it's i love
paris and thus that's
springtime uh but initially your brain
probably read it as i love paris in the
springtime
because attached to the words that have
meaning and filled in the rest
what about on this slide which is a or b
has the darker shade of gray
if you've seen this before you'll know
it's a trick question
as both a and b are exactly the same
shade of gray
however our brains know that shadows
cast
a dark make darkness and so our brains
automatically see
b as being lighter than a because it's
under a shadow
what about on this side are you can you
see the black dots
on the left hand figure are they moving
around
because they're not really there what
about the other two
do they look like squiggly lines or
parallel lines
they are parallel but it's the context
around them that's making your brain
see them differently
or how about here a
and b on the left hand figure are
exactly the same
size but our brains want to see a
as being same with the middle finger
those lines are exactly the same size
the context makes our brain see one as
being smaller than the other
and the circle the orange circles are
both exactly the same size
even knowing this it's very hard
for our brains to truly believe that
even myself i've had to get out and
measure these multiple times
they are in fact exactly the same
all right so would you make a good
witness we're going to have a little bit
of a memory test here
so i'm going to read out a list of words
when i say so
i want you to write down as many as
possible so don't write them down yet
just have a wee listen
bed rest
awake tired
snooze blanket
doze fake
slumber
okay write down as many as you can
remember
all right now i'm going to read them out
again and you can take as many as you
got
bed rest awake
tired snooze blanket
does sleep wake
slumber noise peace
yawn drowsy dreams
so how many did you get and did you
record the word sleep
about 70 of you would have remembered
hearing sleep
even though i never actually said it in
the first list that i read out
the word association and image made you
think of words that were likely in the
list
rather than remembering what was
actually there
and if you didn't misremember sleeps you
likely only remember about five to seven
words
and possibly additional words related to
sleep
that i didn't read out okay so if i
haven't managed to get you on all of the
last ones we'll give one last
figure a go so i want you to cover your
right eye
look at the black star and move slowly
towards the screen
and and tell me what happens to the
coloured star
now you can tell me what happens to the
colour star obviously i'm not going to
be able to hear you
but the color star will disappear at
some point
now this will depend obviously on how
big your screen is how far away you're
sitting
but if you're covering one eye as you
move back and forth
you'll notice that one disappears
so just like our eyes are not able to
see everything our brains are also
not able to take everything in at once
it must ignore
some information and data to find the
easiest route to information processing
and this is what we call cognitive bias
and it's a deviation in judgment whereby
inferences about people situations and
data may be drawn in analogical fashion
contextual bias is the one we talk about
most often in forensic science so
this is a deviation and judgment caused
by exposure to information
that is either irrelevant to the
judgmental task
or inappropriate for consideration
and biases may affect the reliability
and validity of one's observations and
interpretations
and this is why it's so important to
understand it in terms of who runs
reference decision making
i want to be really clear that we're not
talking about intentional or malicious
behavior
so it's not this idea of
getting rid of samples or only testing
certain things that you know will
produce
um inclusionary results or exploratory
results we're not talking about that
we're talking about the things that go
on in your brain that you're really not
aware of
uh now cognitive bias research and
forensic science
really started to take off around uh
2005
2006 with a few uh early studies in the
area of fingerprint exposure
by etl similar and
this came off the back of the brandon
mayfield case where the fbi had
misidentified
his fingerprint in a
in a madrid bombing case and
and what etl found was that when you
present
analysts with contextual information
that suggests
that the fingerprints either do match or
they don't match
in some cases the analysts will
will be biased towards going along with
that particular information
since then there have been
numerous contextual bias studies across
all forensic disciplines
and and i'll be talking a little bit
more about some of the challenges of
these studies later on
um but basically the overall
general design of these is that lay
people or forensic experts are given
data
to interpret so the fingerprints fire
marks blood stains epgs
alongside some form of contextual
information that can be potentially
biasing
then researchers measure the effect of
this uh information on the decisions
that participants produce
now i don't have time to go into the
findings of all of those but what i will
do is highlight
the instances where size can be as
potential
issues
so bias is only found when there is
ambiguous
ambiguity in the evidence or the
evidences of low quality that it may be
distorted
or have parts of it missing
it happens more often when there are
subjective masses of interpretations
when uh there's task irrelevant
contextual information and we will be
talking a little bit more about this
later on
uh because some information of course is
relevant
and necessary to use uh but it's that
task irrelevant information makes
an insulin uh in a negatively biasing
way
uh if you have a lack of training or
competency so
in studies that has compared novice ex
novice analysts to experienced analysts
generally the effect is more pronounced
in novice analysts
and the lack of independent review will
checks and balances
so what are some challenges when
conducting and understanding the
findings of cognitive bias
research
these studies are not particularly easy
to design
and the many factors that it's very hard
to replicate
case work sentences and conditions
uh and because we're trying to produce
ground truth samples
[Music]
and there's often
small sample sizes so this is one of the
critiques of many of the
biased studies is that
some only have five six ten twelve
participants
as these are starting to increase and as
time's gone on we're definitely seeing a
rise
and there's so many variables to consume
this
uh and for example when bloodstream had
an analysis
there's many different mechanisms that
can cause
a particular blood stain so if you
create a study that's only looking at
one particular stain then you
may be missing out on vital information
so generally only testing one part of
the system which is
generally the evaluative and comparative
phase
but there are many steps that lead up to
that in actual case work
that you'll that also need to be tested
in my experience as a bias researcher
there's often resistance from
practitioners and managers to
participate
and psychological contamination is much
harder to identify than
physical contamination
also the measured variable might not be
telling the whole story
and what i mean by this is that there
are challenges in understanding the true
effect of contextual information so the
result that we get
may not account for the fact that
the same analyst can reach different
reach a different opinion on the same
piece of evidence
at different time points in the presence
or absence of contextual information and
this is often referred to as
intra-examiner variability
also different analysts can reach
different opinions on the same piece of
evidence
in the presence or absence of contextual
information we call it
inter-examiner variability
particularly in casework you can be
biased by something other than the
contextual information
for example time and resource pressure
or if you have a culture of
prosecutorial bias
and those are things that is very
difficult to actually assess
in an experimental setting
while trying to be unbiased you may
introduce a different type of bias
and we call this the biased lines force
you can of course be unbiased and reach
the wrong answer
or be biased and reach the right answer
now i have right and wrong answer in
quotation marks because there's of
course
a lot of discussion about what accuracy
really means
in the context of forensic decision
making
but this last point you can be biased
and reach the right answer
and sometimes maybe more likely to reach
the right answer
is something that gets debated in
academic and forensic circles and it is
important to point out
that bias does not equal
error so they're not the same thing so
it's very true that you can be biased
and still reach um the right answer
you just have gone about it in the wrong
way
so what if i reached the right answer uh
there was a paper that came out recently
where the author said
there is every possibility then that
cognitive biases
may actually improve accuracy in certain
decision scenarios
for instance stevenage and bennett found
that task irrelevant contextual
information
a dna match dna unclear or dna does not
match influenced or biased the decisions
of students
when analyzing fingerprint evidence in
both formative
and negative ways
so what they're saying is well if you
have context that leads to more correct
answers
then what's the problem
unfortunately conceptualizing bias in
terms of accuracy and this is a key
point
and that's around the nature of
scientific reasoning so if knowledge
and influence of tasks are relevant
contextual information
if you have that it really undermines
the independent prohibitive value
of the evidence
that is a fact finder may give the
evidence or opinion
more weight than it deserves
uh so let's say for example the
fingerprints
examiner knows the dna result and
they've incorporated that into
their findings and then in court a
fingerprint result is presented as
independent and a dna result is
presented at the distance
the jury or judge does not have no way
of knowing
um how independent that is and how much
how much weight to give each one because
it's being presented as independence yes
it's really not and and this is a double
counting
scenario in addition incorporation of
task irrelevant contextual information
makes assumptions about the correctness
of the extraneous information
and may lead you to explain away
non-corroboratory data
and this is uh what the finding was in
the brandon mayfield case where
um the examiners that there were
inconsistencies
in brandon mayfield's fingerprint
versus the front of the crime scene but
they kind of explained those away
because they were already certain that
they should match
uh also using information from another
field goes beyond the area of expertise
so as an example you could ask
what is the true value of the
fingerprint evidence if it is influenced
by dna evidence
or how you know that you were not
influenced by the reference profile
if you did not have the opportunity to
view the crime scene profile
independent of it
so those are important distinctions to
make and it's also important to know
that information does not
equal bias so having the information
doesn't necessarily mean that you'll be
biased by it and also
even today i hear in working group
meetings people saying
forensic analysts saying but i need bias
to do my job
and i want to make this distinction
because no you don't need bias to do
your job you may need information
but you don't need bias so information
uh is the information that's used to
inform the decision which can be task
relevant or task irrelevant
whereas bias is the undue effect of that
information
so it's when the incidents the
information and
the task of relevant permission has
influenced the decision in
a logical way so there's a distinction
and i think it's important to recognize
that when
uh formulating methods to address it
so when is it appropriate to use
contextual information
the national commission of forensic
sciences put out
a piece in 2015
and that defines what is task relevant
versus what is task
irrelevant and and
how they define it is it's relevant if
it's necessary for drawing conclusions
about the propositions and questions
from the physical evidence that has been
designated for examination
and through the correct application of
an accepted analytic message
by a competent analyst
it's nice to me here to tell you what is
past relevant and task irrelevant but
it's
to make the point that there are various
tasks
during your examination and what may be
relevant in one
may not be relevant in another for
example
if you are at the crime scene collecting
that dna evidence
then it may be necessary to know witness
statements
to determine where it may be appropriate
to sample from
however that information is not going to
be relevant when it comes to
uh evaluating and or analyzing the epg
and when looking at the crime scene
profile
at that point it's not going to be
necessary to look at the reference
profile
in case that has influence on how you
then interpret the crime scene profile
so
it's about breaking down the tasks and
then identifying what's relevant for
that task
uh as well as identifying identifying
what what could be potentially biasing
and this is where contextual information
management comes in
uh the purpose of which is to
shield examiners from potentially
biasing information and that which is
not relevant to their tasks
while still allowing access to the task
relevant
information
now i like this quote from etl drawer
for forensic science to
successfully take on the issue of
contextual bias
it's important that one correctly
considers the risks
that measures are taken when needed and
that they are proportionate and
appropriate
now you thought earlier on i just
discussed the danger zones
those are really the cases where it's
important to have conceptual information
management
it's not necessary to overhaul all
disciplines for all cases but it's about
identifying and understanding where the
risks are and then taking those
appropriate
actions when necessary
there are many different types of
contextual information management
procedures that have been discussed in
the literature
some of them are reasonably simple to do
uh for example at the crime scene
investigator wants to give you a whole
bunch of information
tell you all the theories of the case
and it could be as simple as saying
thanks but no thanks that is if i need
the information i will come and ask for
you
ask it from you however otherwise don't
say anything at all
of course being transparent is really
important
and and can
really help you to identify if later on
down the track a piece of
context that you have relied on is
identified as being
incorrect or invalid you can see exactly
when you used it and how it affected
your decision
and can go back or theoretically go back
and
and change um the course of action that
you would take or
identify if a change is necessary
uh context manager this one's talked
about a lot where somebody has all of
the information
and they only pass on to the analysts
what is
necessary for this for their task at
that particular point
uh independent checking or review this
is another uh
one where which most most
practitioners i talk to have some form
of review
whereby it may be administrative or
technical
um somehow on every case some will do on
a proportion of cases
and the independent part of it is trying
to recognize that
the reviewer may be influenced by what
the first examiner has said
so is it possible you know if the
reviewer
is um
is looking at the case that they already
know how the number of contributors that
you've determined
um in a sample
well does that then influence how they
move forward with with reviewing the
case or is it better for them not to
know that at all and to try and come up
with that on their own
is that a more appropriate way of really
reviewing and assessing the initial
examinations
so there's quite a few different options
here and i'm not going to go through
them all because
it really depends on what discipline
you're in what the task is what
uh your agency kind of setup is like
but i'm more than happy for anyone to
contact me later on and i can
talk through various options specific to
your situation
and what we know is that there are
benefits
of contextual information management
beyond just minimizing bias
so you may be of the view that bias is
not so much of an issue for you or in
your
agency but there are benefits um to
implementing this
first and foremost maintains
transparency and integrity in the
decision making process
by mapping decision points you can
identify
potential areas for improved efficiency
and you know there's there may be some
benefits that you don't even realize yet
a way that you can
speed things up or yeah create
processes that are more efficient
it can help you to thoughtfully question
the true value and scientific basis of
the interpretation
when you examine only the data so if
you're not able to reach an opinion
in the absence of additional contextual
information
then should you be reaching an opinion
at all
so as i said in the beginning it's those
cases of ambiguity that
are the most problematic so when you're
really not quite sure or there's not
enough information there
that's when you're tempted to reach out
to get more information to make you a
little bit more certain
but it may be at that point that you
think well if i need more information
maybe the right answer is
that we cannot produce an opinion
there's not enough information there's
not enough data here
to support an opinion without context
therefore we cannot produce an opinion
at all
another benefit is that as we've
discussed fact finders are better able
to assign appropriate weight to evidence
when they know that each piece of
evidence is truly independent
and the expert is able to defend via
challenges in court
so if you're a practitioner listening to
this you may
may now have experienced
[Music]
defense attorney is bringing up the
pcast report the nas reports
um studies on the potential for bias
if you have context management
procedures in place then you are able to
defend those
and understand really what those reports
are saying and why they're saying it
and of course safe adjusted outcomes and
that's
that's really what this is all about is
um
trying to make sure what we're doing
really is the safest way we can be doing
it
and thinking beyond bias to all
human factor issues now you know
initially
studies were just looking at bias but
now what we really understand is that
there's so many more parts of the system
that humans make decisions within
and it may not just be are you biased
when looking at this piece of evidence
um but how reliable and valid
are your opinions in general is the
discipline in general
and what's the efficacy of training and
competency standards
so these are things that are being
looked at by various groups
for example the role of management
creating a positive aeroculture
impact of wording and statements process
mapping
and in osak the organization of
scientific area committees
um there is a designated committee the
human factors
committee that is embedded into every
discipline to try and understand some of
these issues
as well as minus but thinking much
further beyond that
and most along with nij's
uh have expert working groups
in human factors for various disciplines
and their role really is to understand
the entire system and how
uh the human side of that can be
improved for yeah for safer justice
outcomes
so thank you for sticking it out if you
have
uh and these are my contact details i'm
more than happy if anyone would like to
reach out and ask
any questions uh if you have any
particular
concerns within your own lab uh or if
you
you know are interested in in looking at
contextual information management then
please do reach out and happy to answer
any questions
and i think i'm just about on 30 minutes
i hope that you've managed to stick it
out and
that you're all home safe and well thank
you very much